Congress has a March 5th deadline to
hammer out an immigration plan before
daca protections expire for about
800,000 of the so-called dreamers
Democrats rejected president Trump's
offer last week of amnesty for nearly 2
million illegal immigrants in exchange
for border security and legal
immigration cuts but another plan exists
that should be put on the table
Republican Senator David Perdue is one
of the men behind it he joins us now
with more senator always great to see
you I see a run into you at a vent on
Saturday I said you better come on the
show and here you are so thank you so
you and Tom cotton in my view came up
with an original idea that kind of in
some ways mirrors what was going on on
the in the hill with Goodlatte and Mike
McCall and it was focused on the 800,000
daca people who are not kids they were
are adults now for the most part and
then it you did the chain migration yeah
and to that end a Visa Lottery and then
like a three at three or four days later
suddenly it's at 1.8 million how did you
go from 800 to 1.8 and was that thought
process because you needed to pick up a
few people that's great to see you again
Laura you know a year ago you had Tom
cotton and myself on here and we started
then with a very conservative approach
to this to solve the immigration of the
legal immigration problem once and for
all and we warned about the diversity
lottery and we said we needed to end the
chain my migration and so what we've
done now the president has laid out I
believe a framework that's ingenious
because we're going to find out if
people are really serious about solving
this immigration problem on both sides
and I think we got the framework to
actually get it done now finally my
listeners are livid I have to tell you
I'm like I've done this on the show for
now last three or four days and like
well when did he campaign on this like
and my point is if you want to if you
want cuts and legal immigration which is
the big number a million green cards
every year most of those are based not
on merit but on extended family ties
aunts uncles cousins twice removed
they all have everyone's coming in right
I need to do it that way but look I'm
not an amnesty person I think it's it
hurts people feelings
and sensibility who've been waiting in
line for a long time what do you say to
those
because Americans were upset and then
the people waiting in line who played by
the rules the president is really laid
out he wants an end to daca and what
that means is is that he wants to
provide certainty they're not going to
get in front of anybody but what he's
also done is given the conservatives of
his party what he promised me you would
do a safer secure border with a wall he
wants to end chain migration which is
the most insidious part of this it's
what's caused us to be here and then we
know we have a issue with the diversity
lottery chain migration I've got to play
this for you Kristin Gillibrand who's
gonna run for president in 2020 she's
already kicking off her campaign
practically on the view this morning on
chain migration let's watch I think a
lot of President Trump's rhetoric is
racist and let's be very clear when
someone uses the phrase chained
migration it is intentional and trying
to demonize families literally trying to
demonize families and make it a racist
slur you know Laura is very interesting
they were out of touch when they tried
to shut the government down the Schumer
shutdown was so out of touch with
America but the idea that the term chain
migration was created by lyndon b
johnson i think he was a democrat bill
clinton also called for an end to chain
migration when he and Barbara Jordan
wanted to go to a merit-based
immigration system like Canada in
Australia so this is nothing more than
Democrats revealing how far out of touch
they are with mainstream America but
two-thirds of America wants to end chain
migration into diversity lottery fix the
daca problem and build that wall and
make our border secure by the way she
kept saying chained she's changed the
terms to be a needy at the end of shan't
totally um these are some of the polls
America's view on immigration sixty-five
percent want not dock a deal with strong
border security sixty eight percent
opposed the Visa Lottery 81% want legal
immigration reduced that is that's
always the case whether it's a Gallup
poll or the Harvard Harris poll that
just came out and 61% think current
border security is inadequate but you
have people like Steve King who was on
my show on Friday he said this the
numbers are just stunning to see that
President Trump has proposed 1.8 that
one 1.8 million
amnesty to illegals I think that this
will demoralize so very many of his
supporters and how do we get back now to
a place where we need to be with us well
the answer is very simple keep fires
focused on the prize and the prize is to
end the problems that got us here in the
first place chain migration diversity
lottery and that porous border we have
in with Mexico and no more amnesties
after this this will be the last well
this is the idea is to end the creation
of the problem that created this crisis
in the first place it's gonna they're
gonna make you go up to 3 million 4
million well I'll say 5 million is it
gonna keep going nobody's gonna do
nothing it's going to be 7 million or
more that's what people don't realize
this is an opportunity to stop this once
and for all
you think the Democrats are gonna get
enough Democrats to support this well
we're gonna find out you know if they're
really serious about solving the daca
problem I want to give you a win on
Domino senator no they don't we're gonna
find out senator Perdue thank you so
much